the January 25th big story jury clears
time of malice ending sharone libel case
in a story down here panel reprimands
magazine staff story by Herbert Denton
Dateline New York and it says a federal
jury found today that time incorporated
did not act with quote actual malice in
describing former Israeli defense
minister Ariel Sharon's role in the 1982
massacre of hundreds of Palestinians at
two refugee camps in Beirut while
rendering the bittersweet verdict in
favor of time jury foreman Richard Zug
45 a computer programmer read on behalf
of the six-member panel a statement
reprimanding quote certain time
employees particularly correspondent
david hale of a quote for acting
negligently and carelessly in reporting
and verifying the information in one
paragraph of the february 83 time cover
story at issue in the case coleman
mccarthy syndicated columnist for The
Washington Post what is the impact of
this decision on journalism in general
and columnist like yourself well I think
it's a reminder that we always have to
check our facts make the extra phone
call verify what we suspect to be true
but aren't completely sure is true and
and that's always a job that all of us
have to be faithful to you do I do any
journalist Time magazine des Moines
Register a Miami Herald anyone like that
this is the commentary page of The
Washington Times in Smith heme stone who
is the editor in chief of the Washington
Times on a show program with his earlier
in the week over here as this to say but
they were treated fairly the headline
says but here in his editorial piece it
says in the first place nowhere in the
Constitution or the Bill of Rights is
there anything resembling the quote
public's right to know end of quote
show it to me and I'll eat a copy of the
first ten amendments of the steps of the
Jefferson Memorial at high noon on July
4th the First Amendment guarantees the
right to free speech oral and written
period in parentheses underground
presses had played a major role in
marshalling pro-independence sentiment
before and during Revolutionary War the
First Amendment was designed to protect
the right of a man to own and operate a
printing press any quote right of the
public to know is at best a derivative
and subject to interpret
what do you think of mr. Helme stones
comment specifically about how the press
uses the First Amendment to protect
itself well first of all in mr. Helme
stump you very well eat he has an
enormous appetite he could very well eat
the whole monument I I think I think we
ought to be discussing what the First
Amendment means and unless you're an
absolutist and just stick to the letter
of the law I think there's a lot of
flexibility in what that law means and
then the thing I worry about as far as
the press goes is is when you look
around the rest of the world how many
journalists are in prison how many are
censors how many can't write at all I
mean we're so spoiled in this country
American journalists I was down to Haiti
a few months ago and there they make $35
a week a big salary for them and you
can't write what you want we're always
in and out of jail they're not they're
not quibbling about about about
constitutional nuances they're out there
being censored and hurt and victimized
so I think I think when the American
press wants to get worried about
something don't think of ourselves so
much and think about all of our brothers
and sisters around the world who are in
prison right now 300 or 400 I belong I
was a founding member of the Committee
to Protect Journalists and we send
delegations to - to countries that are
jailing our comrades and colleagues and
trying to get them out of jail like at
least live a little bit here we make a
lot of money and and walk all glamour
boys and glamour girls and you're
interviewing me and I'm gonna quote you
and all this stuff and Wow there's a lot
of suffering out there
Coleman McCarthy is a syndicated
columnist with the Washington Post how
long have you been a syndicated
columnist well I've been with the posts
in 68 running columns and I've been
syndicated for about seven years now
he's also the author of this recent book
and it's called involvement so you see
there's a picture of Coleman Cartman
Coleman McCarthy there riding his bike I
understand you rode your bike in this
cold weather today well well I do I
don't own a car and I gave it away about
ten years ago to as a protest against
the oil company's manipulations and and
I found to be extremely liberating not
to own a car you once you make the brake
it's it's a great it's a great freedom
not to be chained the things are always
breaking down they're not safe and and
bycicle is as you know the most
efficient means of traveling except for
your feet and and I also run marathon so
so I'm doing the two most efficient
things you can as well has not given the
oil companies or Detroit the
satisfaction have taken some nickels
from me
how many marathons have you run eighteen
I've run a few ten K's in my day but I
must admit I've never run a marathon
okay that's what one-fourth of oh that's
very good
that's a nice distance why do you call
your new book involvements why that name
well I am involved in a lot of issues I
I'm a columnist I think we ought not to
sit in the sidelines all the time and
Justin just be neutral observers I try
to be a fair writer I try to be being
honest writer but as far as staying
uninvolved I can't do that I've got to
get involved I believe in certain things
I have convictions I'm against Wars I'm
a pacifist I believe in in in school so
I go into and I couldn't the schools a
lot in your columns in your columns that
you appear in The Washington Post every
Saturday you often refer to that that
you are a pacifist why is this so
important why do you put it into your
column so often well peace I think is
the most important issue we have in the
world right now
and either we solve problems violently
or non-violently you have no other
choice as Martin Luther King for whom we
now have a national holiday we have two
national holidays now in the country one
after General who believed in Wars and
believe in killing enemies George
Washington it was a higher
hired men to go out and kill folks who
disagree with us and we have Martin
Luther King who believed the opposite
that there are other ways to solve
problems King said it's either
non-violence or non-existence that
that's all we have so so I think that
Gandhi and Albert Schweitzer and and
Dorothy that day and Merton a long list
of people I've been educating us to
solve problems other ways I want to read
from one of your columns it's in your
book involvement it's it's called the
media money talks and this program is
about journalism so I'll read from it
and I'd like you to comment on a quote
from the media money talks the senators
are stupid a burr is compared with many
in the media they are limited to $2,000
a speech but journalists from television
anchormen two prominent syndicated
columnist earned fees as high as fifteen
thousand per lecture at the cash
register for much of this is the
Washington speaker's bureau you go on to
say that with money talking talking for
money means that the public trust is at
stake the credibility of the media would
be enhanced if fees were a matter of
public record as well as other sources
of outside income for those in the news
business media figures hot in the
marketplace are not public employees as
senators are but they are in positions
to shape the discussion of public policy
the larger richer and more influential
the media become the more they have a
duty to maintain their integrity
elaborate on that for us well I'd like
to see all of us put down how much money
we make from from outside outside
speeches the public ought to be informed
about that safa if you see a columnist
writing well the funeral industry huh
needs to be less controlled by
government less regulations well maybe
this fellow was it was given a nice
speech to the funeral Association when
it meets and Hawaii LA wherever they
meet to talk about the price of caskets
and embalming fluid uh how much how much
did this journalist make to go out there
and say down with the government and
then it comes back here and writes a
column all the funeral leave him alone
they're good guys
are you suggesting that colonists are
being bought off when they speak for
$15,000 or speakers people I'm
suggesting that when
he changes hands that can another
customer ought to be aware about it and
I'd be willing to disclose how much I
make and and and and every other
journalist I'm not hiding anything and
so that so that it take you go to a
speech you go you hang around with the
guys are all nice fellows and I give you
their spiel it's access you get a little
access and then they're not give me that
money to hear your beautiful words only
that's not being naive about it and and
and so that's just I trust your mother
but cut the cards let me read from
another one of your columns it's called
hobnob read journalism and I quote it
says and it's talking about the
relationship between George Will and
President Reagan and specifically before
he was elected president than once he
was in an office and it says quote as
Reagan and will stick together through
thick and thick loyalty of another kind
is the issue loyalty to journalistic
standards instead of keeping an arm's
length from the Reagan campaign and the
name of professional detachment we'll
link to it arm-in-arm readers assumed he
was an observer not a participant a few
of them may also have assumed that will
the dutiful Republican had read and
understood Orwell's advice quote
whatever else he does in the service of
his party a person should never write
for it he should make it very clear that
his writing is a thing apart elaborate
on that for us well I think well I don't
really respect him when he did funny
Dutch things like that he was just I
don't know what his motives were but it
was the way he defended himself
afterwards and and people like Mike
Royko and others myself included
criticized him and oh he he's on a high
horse as it is all mostly anyway and so
he he was a and even on a higher moral
horse no you who are you to question my
ethics was his argument and so I don't
think this I don't think there's a lot
of when he compared him with people like
Mary mcgrory and as he did stone for
example that was it people of you know
of absolute integrity and they wouldn't
associate with some political figure to
do their a bidding for them my heavens
are you a close personal friend of any
of the major politicians in the country
i I've never had one in my home I would
and I don't I don't foresee that that
happening I I don't have many
acquaintances among them but I I
wouldn't I don't think you want to have
friends in in those jobs yeah friends
with folks living on the street
fool minds are open we'd like to hear
what's on the front page of your
newspaper those numbers are there at the
bottom of your screen and please feel
free to give us a call if you have your
morning newspaper because this shows
about journalism this is the front page
of the New York Times for this Friday
right in the middle of the front page
the story we were looking at a little
while ago time cleared of labelling
sharone but negligent reporting is cited
story by arnold lub suck love love us
excuse me a jury found yesterday that in
1983 Time magazine article although it
contained a false and defamatory
paragraph did not libel Ariel Cerrone
because the magazine did not publish it
with quote serious doubts as to its
truth and we go on down here and it says
well we came here to prove that Time
magazine lied mister sharone said and we
managed to prove that Time magazine did
lie what does this do to journalists in
general do you think that when the
public sees headlines like this and mr.
Stroh insane things like this gives
gives readers the feeling that reporters
aren't quite as honest or aren't quite
as accurate as they should be Wow well I
think I think everybody knows we're not
always accurate I mean time puts out the
size of a book every week we put out a
book every morning as far as about
60,000 words and I think you'd be naive
to think every one of those 60,000 words
is absolutely accurate this is what Ben
Sargent who is the editorial cartoonist
with the Austin american-statesman he
was on our program in Dallas for the
Republican convention this is what he
says about the whole affair and you see
Time magazine and it's a cover and the
upper right hand corner key story it
says irresponsible boobs of the year is
this going to give journalism a black
eye that it can't recover from no no no
no no no no it's just a little bruised
there was no malice proven malice is
very hard to prove anyway but I don't
think I've known very I think I've ever
known any journalist who's malicious a
lot of us are asleep to wait in the
morning
and and don't make enough phone calls
but but I think that laziness is not is
not the same as being malicious about
things Fredericksburg Virginia good
morning do you have your morning paper
my local paper the freelance star uh-huh
what's uh what's on the front page
anything about the Cherone trial no the
article in the middle here is that the
University of Virginia picks president
from Wisconsin head of the University of
Wisconsin System of Higher Education was
elected today to become the sixth
president of the earth of the University
of Virginia something we've been
tracking for a long time there is a bill
now in the General Assembly to allow
uranium mining and milling in Virginia
and we invert expert or in the
Rappahannock watershed and this is one
of the areas that they want to let you
rhenium money and milling occur so there
was a hearing in Richmond and we
participated in that her in trying to
block uranium mining and milling in
Virginia okay
by any chance does koma McCarthy's
columns appear there in your newspaper
does Coleman McCarthy's column appear in
your newspaper what do you think of his
columns about journalists and I think
there's a lot of good journalists and I
like him and I think that a few people
probably create problems for a lot of
people and I really think that the
papers do a good job we do get the post
on weekends and occasionally the
Richmond times-dispatch from Richmond
okay but by and large I feel it but the
writers today do an excellent job
Fredericksburg Virginia thank you very
much for the phone call how many
newspapers carry your column I'm in
about sixty and most of the big ones
around the country Los Angeles Miami
Dallas Chicago Boston
Philadelphia now is it up to you as an
individual columnist to go out and sell
your column so that it appears in these
newspaper while we have a salesman for
The Washington Post a syndicate and he
travels the country and and I certainly
do visit when I go around the country
speaking and visiting schools and so
forth I always drop into the local a
Mahatma and bow and scrape and tell him
I'd love to be in the Dubuque Herald
whatever it is and talk to an editor do
you call him Mahatma I go like that call
him sahi course I do
boston boston massachusetts you're with
us this morning do you have the Boston
Globe what's on the front page the
left-hand column
clerics Castro meet in Cuba law that's
Archbishop lar is among the group for
the Hmong group a five-man delegation of
American Roman Catholic leaders
including the Boston Archbishop in
yesterday with Fidel Castro what do you
could you read us the first paragraph on
that of that story I don't think it's in
the front page of any of the newspapers
I just about read it here with Fidel a
five-man delegation of American Roman
Catholic leaders including Boston
Archbishop Bernard vomit yesterday was
Cuban President Fidel Castro who seemed
determined to convince them of the
advantages of his socialist way of life
well what is their purpose in going down
there does your article say I think it
was it just to meet with clergymen with
other clergymen down there and to get a
feeling for freedom of religion and and
their school systems and see what was
going on okay what else is on the front
page okay I we have opposite bat on the
right hand column Reagan defense aid for
contrast
he's new danger Nicaragua Allies then
beneath the picture of Archbishop lon
and Fidel Castro Sheikh is shaking hands
is a feature story of the Israeli
pullout troops voiced relief at quitting
Lebanon but regret about leaving
Christians behind then you go down in
the Chiron story is right beneath that
time did not rival cherone jury rules
what do you think of that decision well
I think the decision on a very mixed
feelings
I keep pretty good track not only the
Boston press but also of the Israeli
press and I think that I share the
feeling that of a lot of Israel a lot of
Israelis who are not admirers of general
sharone but if considered time reporting
to be so biased and so distorted that
we're glad to see time get a punch in
the nose because it really deserves it
okay thanks for the call any response
well I think that the press I think we
have to we have to like in the coal mine
disaster in Utah it had helicopters
flying in the about 300 journalists and
reporters and then the story is over and
these fellows and and women ought to go
back to Washington to the federal Mine
Safety health agency and do some serious
investigating there that's why we need
to have 300 journalists go in there find
out what's going on with that agency
what are the problems there what are
their deficiencies and and and we often
just go to the fire when the flames are
at their height and you find few
reporters covering covering federal
agencies and and telling citizens where
their money's going also on the front
page of The Washington Times today a
picture space shuttle discovery lifts
off the launch pad at the Kennedy Space
Center yesterday afternoon to embark on
the nation's first secret mission and an
AP photo and as usual a beautiful color
photo of the shuttle taking off but the
story I want to refer to is just to the
right of that picture and says u.s.
searches for sources of spy shot leaks
the US government has begun several
investigations to determine the sources
of news leaks about a spy satellite
aboard the space shuttle discovery
Pentagon said yesterday disclosure came
almost as a shuttle soared into orbit
from Cape Canaveral after a secret
countdown designed to prevent the
Soviets from knowing the exact launch
time what did you think of the
synchronous that surrounds this space
shuttle mission well I've been against
the space of the space circus it's not a
mission then that's not called a mission
that's called a circus and now and now
you have to have the Pentagon moving in
on it
yeah so we've just been sending up these
rockets to learn how to kill more
efficiently I guess that says that
what's going on I think I think as soon
as you see the Army and the Air Force
coming around something's fishy and
something's being something's wrong
about one of the things that the
military is protesting against is news
leaks they wanted it to be secret some
of the information about this mission
got out and journalists are printing it
you think that's right oh sure this I
mean what that what are we talking about
here these things I mean you send to
rock it up you're gonna keep a rocket
secret what are we talking about and
what's it going up there what's it going
up there in the first place for we need
to be feeding we have a while full of
hungry people and with him with what I
was squandering money on on this other
sorry
so the generals can go play war games in
the sky what are you talking about
Indianapolis Indiana you are an ex
caller do you have your morning
newspaper and it's the Indianapolis Star
is that correct that's right and what's
on the front page well the president
sounds alarm on Central American threat
PLO two nations cited shuttle blast-off
with spy satellite down in the bottom
that's got in a single column time wins
and labral super sarong what do you
think about that especially the libel
case well I'm glad that same Wonder suit
because I think that more things are
going to have to be brought out about
government officials and government and
here in Indianapolis this is a very
conservative paper than your naturist
are we only have two daily papers here
they didn't have to start and they
didn't Aptus news and both of them are
very conservative and I'm a minority
person myself and I know that's a lot of
things that goes on well we have a
corrupt corrupt government a good
corrupt legal system and you cannot get
either the visual or the print media to
print anything that it's against these
two bureaucracies I think would like the
answer yes what is this suggestion about
what would you do about things like
before he answers if I can ask you what
do you think this does to journalism do
you know we just showed you the cartoon
that suggests that Time magazine is
irresponsible boobs of the year do you
it hurts journalism drastically this
decision no I think it's helped so
alright there's everyone does their own
opinion but frankly I think these things
had to be brought out and all the times
I'm aware that you can't get the legal
documents to prove your case but
invariably you would know that these
cases are true all right Indianapolis
thanks for the call Coleman McCarthy
Indianapolis has has I agree a couple of
conservative papers aren't there but
they have a wonderful congressman Andy
Jacobs who I think is one of the best
members of the House of Representatives
and whatever the deficiencies in the
store on the other paper Andy Andy more
than makes up for again I think I think
we ought to worry about what the
reporters are doing in the daily beats
this is a this is one case I think and I
think it there was no malice obviously
but there was perhaps some some hasty
hasty journalism this is the New York
Times editorial page and it's response
is beyond an absence of malice and I'll
read the second paragraph it says
constructive in salya Tory from our
interested perspective in the trenches
trenches of journalism the verdict
affirms the laws special protections for
a free press but also underscores the
obligations that the media bear public
officials remain on notice that they
cannot easily punish criticism with
libel suits the press is on notice that
it can nonetheless be held accountable
and that it needs to provide better
forms of rebuttal
and redress that's the New York Times
editorial page st. Louis Missouri you're
our next caller do you have your morning
newspaper oh I'm sending my wife on how
the windchill factor is pretty high here
we haven't been hot together yet they're
supposed to spatch what I wanted to
mention was something about Jesse Helms
attempt to take over CBS mhm I don't
know if all your listeners are aware of
that but that's probably the best thing
to come down the line and a long time to
be able to take one of the three major
networks and make it into a conservative
what it's been so nice to get a
conservative view out of New York City
and I out of Washington DC and I was
wondering if your guests would tell us
if he thinks he has a plan to see a
conservative or a Zia I know it's hard
to determine conservative or liberal but
when I hear somebody sit and say we
shouldn't be spending
money on space programs if we stopped
our space program completely do you
think the Russians would stop or do you
think you would you you you said there
an advocated that we should be taking
care of our problems at home the
conservative viewpoint is let the people
back here at home take care of
themselves and if we stopped on our
space program do you think the Russians
would stop no they would control the
frontier and we'd be at their at their
will and beckoned we could they'd have
they'd have the whole bulb the whole
they'd have space we're stopping now
caller before you even for he answers
let me ask you a question you brought up
Jesse Helms and his asking conservatives
around the country to buy stock and CB s
if you agree with that principle have
you gone out and bought stock in CB s
I'm supposed to send him a proxy showing
out i'll buy as much as i can because if
that's what it takes for all the
conservatives in the united states to by
CBS and like they said yesterday on your
program fire dan Rather if that's what
it takes to get the conservative voice
to the people they can't listen to
c-span here in st. louis i would think
all of the st. louis area where all the
poor people are they can't get c-span
they the cables not even there and they
probably couldn't afford it if that if
they if it was available in the city so
the only way we're going to get the
conservative voice or another opposing
side to what this gentleman sitting
there saying is we're gonna have to get
one of the station's bought go in there
and say dan Rather i'm sorry you're
fired you're too liberal and if I owned
the Washington Times I'd say you mean to
say you're advocating stopping the space
program to feed people back here at home
st. Louis hold one second let's get a
response from Coleman McCarthy two
points like you to defend your stand on
the space program and what do you think
of Jesse Helms proposal to buy stock at
CBS well I'm a little wary of people
always worried about the Russians and
getting ahead of us and the Russians are
gonna do that this man is obviously is
it has as a russophobia
and if you look at American trading with
Russia American corporations have never
been trading more with the Soviet Union
so this idea that somehow oh oh the
Russians are going to do it first we've
been
paralyzed been shooting ourselves in the
feet with that with that the disastrous
neuroses for the past 30 or 40 years and
and our kids grow up hating the Russians
fearing them and it's analyst says that
it's endless throughout history and if
people will read history and study the
relations between enemies and countries
and wars perhaps we can make a
breakthrough about this about this
sudden this are this long festering
hatred of the Soviet Union that's
incredible so this man wants to know we
gotta get up there stat don't worry
about that people here are not eating
anything gotta beat those Russians and
the Russians are hungry we're hungry and
meanwhile squandering immense amounts of
money on weapons and these and these and
these moon shots it's madness what about
Jesse Helms senator Helms proposal to
buy stock in CBS and therefore for some
more conservative viewpoint on the
network oh oh I didn't know Helms I
don't I don't regard him with I don't
think he's really a serious think
there's anybody regard him as a serious
thinking anymore I don't I don't find
many people that do I think this is just
just just another another game he's
playing it gets a headline format too
but but he's really one of the most I
think at least regarded members of the
Senate by other senators I don't mind I
have high regard for conservatives like
Alan Simpson for example is a
wonderfully a good conservative senator
but he's no he's no he's no obsessive
the way Helms is no I very feel regard
Holmes seriously in the US Senate
Lakewood New Jersey you're an ex caller
go ahead please yes I read the Asbury
Park Press and it's an afternoon paper
so I have yesterday afternoon the all
the headlines are local except for one
on the top it says new figures show
inflation held in check and that's
mainly all that's all the national news
that's on there I wanted to trauma
three different things but I'll be fast
first of all the strategic defense
initiative I feel is the ultimate use of
space and I'm sure it's what President
Kennedy had in mind when he initiated
the space program a protective umbrella
for our country also on am this is
another topic on a PBS public television
show called the Constitution a delicate
balance I don't know if you've seen it
it's a it's a forum a
question-and-answer forum and the lawyer
asked the editor of the LA Times if he
would print a story if the national
security security was at stake and the
editor said yes he would if he felt that
the American citizens had had a right to
know this particular thing now this
sounds to me as though the LA Times is
deciding a matter of national security I
know I would rather have my security
protected then then hear this story I
hope you understand what I'm trying to
say if the government says it's a matter
of national security I don't want the
paper deciding whether I should hear it
or not okay
Lakewood let's get a response from our
guest Colin McCarthy well everybody's
got a different definition of national
security
mine happens to be I think will be very
secure country when our people are fed
when our kids are in good schools when
our hospitals are taking care of the
elderly people when people have enough
money and enough jobs to handle their
fuel bills when our cars are safe when
our our workplaces are not are not full
of hazards and killing us then when we
have enough people to make the mine safe
that's national security we have enough
weapons now I mean it's incredible the
Arsenal we have and will not only have
our own weapons but under Reagan in the
first four years weapons procurement
which is where you really find out
what's going on with the weapons
spending and procurement it increased by
about ninety percent so so I think we're
very insecure country right now the more
weapons you have the more insecure you
become you as a columnist if you came
across information
that the Pentagon was saying was
national security asked you not to print
it would you print it
oh I of course I would I would of course
I would of course I mean I mean why I
don't agree with their our defining of
security number one I don't think the
more weapons you have the more secure I
think the more insecure you are the more
you need to have violence Martin Luther
King Gandhi Jesus Christ
Amos Buddha Schweitzer I've all been
saying the morph are the more a violent
force you need are the more afraid you
are the more insecure you're going to
become so either you believe that as I
do or you go along with what the
generals are saying I don't believe the
generals I think they're wrong about
national security so I don't accept how
they define national security so I'm
going to print it across I am San
Francisco California good morning do you
have the Chronicle or the examiner with
you today what's on the front page
[Music]
there's a picture of a lady in a bikini
outside I guess she's cold but there's
also there's a funny little story I
didn't get to read it
yeah goosebumps are you oh no no I'm
fine we're really I mean you know it's
cold here lately but what we call cold
is about 40 degrees and I'm sure a lot
of people out there think that that's
not very cold that's like a springtime
what's on the front page besides the
picture of the woman they have a 50
million claimed in I Time magazine wins
a Sharron libel case the Reagan says
Iran is aiding Sandinistas space shuttle
takes off on a secret mission
Union Carbide view at a plant got the
safety warning Oregon picked a lottery
operator caller before you go further
let me ask you very quickly what do you
think of this space shuttle and it's
secret mission well I don't think it's a
secret for one thing and I don't see how
can anything like should it be secret if
the Pentagon says it is no I'm you know
that's the Pentagon they're telling you
you know the Pentagon and like mr.
McCarthy it sure is nice to hear
morning huh makes me feel good to wake
up to him huh you know they've been
doing this for a long time back in the
past they did lie to us I don't see why
they're not lying now okay another thing
I want to say is I was watching during
the allaire report last week and Gary
Hart was on and they were asking him
about this and he sort of agreed to
somewhat of a research program in this
but the twenty six billion dollars and I
think the problem is most people don't
know what 26 billion dollars is and it
would be nice if the newspapers could
actually I don't know how they could
explain it to people that that's twenty
six one hundred million dollars and I
know what you can get for that it's
unbelievable all right San Francisco
thanks for the call Coleman McCarthy oh
I'm glad that gentlemen is having a nice
wake-up call for me I'm sure I'm ruining
some other people's mornings I hope I am
oh they squandered the money over
there's immense amounts of money that
that that place spends and the peace
academy bill as you know Carl just went
through this Senate in house and that's
14 million my 14 million is about as
about 10 percent of what the of what the
militarists spend on their musicians and
you know to play the bands and they took
the trumpets when they you know the
generals retire and things like that and
and here we're supposed to have a peace
Institute with the crumbs from the bands
and the orchestra's ten percent of the
money was supposed to have a peace
academy now well it's a little progress
I mean benaiah I'm cheering it on this
is the recent book by Coleman McCarthy
syndicated columnist it's called
involvement and one of your iPad's in
this it's on education and I quote you
say it is the shame of American schools
that the young are not taught even the
basics about pacifism and non-violence
we raise our children in a culture
saturated with violence and then wonder
why individuals groups and nations keep
opting for fists guns and nukes as the
way to settle their differences well I
believe that I
school now I've been teaching schools
and I've been teaching in a public high
school near my office for a couple years
in teaching non-violence and I'm not
teaching an American you an
undergraduate and graduate cost three
credit cross-scar you went to a you
you're one of our foreign products and I
started out last summer with two
students didn't want to take a chance on
learning about peace right away of
course so then I got up the next
semester to 15 and now I have a hundred
the cell is a big peace movement
starting here in the au campus here in
Washington and the kids are hungry to
hear about they're sick of war they are
sick of the generals raising more war
games in Honduras and Lebanon and
bringing the kids home and coffins and
they're hungry to hear about other ways
to solve problems than by violence and
there are other ways we have a history
of it and unless we teach our children
that there are other ways to solve
problems and by hitting somebody with
your fists or getting a gun or getting a
nuke it's going to keep on going and I'm
in the school's doing what I can to make
sure that gets out front page of The
Washington Post today the story that our
last caller referred to Reagan calls
Iran Libya and PLO a quote new danger in
Central America story by David Hoffman
first paragraph reads President Reagan
attempting to escalate pressure on the
Sandinista government of Nicaragua
charged yesterday that a quote new
danger in Central America is quote the
support being given the Sandinistas by
the Iranian regime of the Ayatollah
Ruhollah Khomeini as well as by libya
and the Palestine Liberation
Organization let's go to Austin Texas
good morning Austin do you have the
Austin american-statesman with you today
good you get an a-plus then what's on
the front page of the Austin American
states
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who's the picture by is it we'll take a
close look at this one is it this the
same photo you're talking about okay
that was that's that's on all of the
papers here it's on the Washington Times
Russian post and also here on the
Washington Times go ahead well a federal
jury did say that
Time magazine acted negligently and
carelessly in its reporting by simply
saying that do you think that's going to
hurt journalism or even scare some
journalists do you think that the court
should have gone as far as giving
cherone the 50 million he asked for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Austin Texas thanks for the call I hold
up the front page of The Washington Post
story down here in the right hand corner
I'd like to get your comment on mr.
McCarthy it's about the nomination of
Edie Meese and it says repayment
question for me story of Jacob a picture
of Jacob Stein to the right and a story
reads independent council Jacob a Stein
has told a panel of judges that Attorney
General designate edwin meese the third
might not be entitled to reimbursement
of seven hundred thousand dollars in
legal fees just apart Justice Department
sources said yesterday in a sealed
document in the US Court of Appeal
here Stein raised legal and policy
issues showing that quote it's not a
foregone conclusion that Mies gets the
money end of quote according to a source
familiar with the document however Stein
suggested grounds on which Misa might be
entitled to some repayment lease
incurred these fees defending himself
against charges that he was not fit to
be the next Attorney General what do you
think of this story call me McCarthy I
hope he doesn't get the money I don't
think I don't think I oughta oh you
ought to be repaying our money too did
it for Mises he's he's the man after all
that said that said the bums gone to
soup kitchens to chisel I get free food
while he that the fees are little
shorter money came over to this came
over local soup kitchen they're about
six or seven soup kitchens and near the
White House and he's always welcome if
he's a little short of funds we'll take
care of him then I go over I go over and
help buy the soup kitchen every Sunday
morning and I'll keep her I'll keep a
special miss a bowl for him the seven
hundred grand no way yep
the Ethics in Government Act says that
if someone is appointed for a public
better or a federal position and then
they have to defend themselves legally
that the government reimburse them
because they only incurred those costs
defending themself because they were
nominated to this public position well
let's find out the facts but according
to what a lawyer Stein says there are
some questions and I'm glad he's raising
the questions before we here we here we
have the Reaganites coming to the city
against the government government
handouts and it hey here you have a guy
wanting a handout from the feds
so which way they want it they want
government handouts or the I don't they
but when it comes to himself Oh give me
that seven hundred thousand strike use a
little bit inconsistent ed meese will
begin confirmation hearings in the
Senate Judiciary Committee next week and
we'll be showing those to you live here
on c-span Spring Valley California go
ahead please good morning
on our front page we have us the o-town
made the flooded prospect opening and
then we have about our mayor and then we
have about the Chiron faith and that's
what I'm really calling fast and I guess
it may be it is kind of lasting I've got
two small kids I've always taught them
about the freedom of press and about our
newspapers about reading and being
informed and getting both sides but you
know when I say about the Chiron Jason
when I am I'm old enough where in I
remember the peace movement very well
service now remember what the people of
is did for our military men okay and
when I speak gentlemen like you and your
attitude and oppressive attitude because
we have hardly any checks and balances
on our friend the net worth problem is
as I believe you make charges and you
make these statements and we know we
have no way of knowing whether you're
the ones that ally you know and we used
to sit up there and say about security
you're taking up here in your san diego
union okay spring Spring Valley thanks
for the call Coleman McCarthy well I
I respect the woman's feelings and and I
know it is that is widely shared that
the press is not fair that we heard a
lot of people and and I'm sure many of
us have have have been guilty of
offenses and errors
and not highly oppressing or CREB I
agree I'm one of the big press critics
in this country I think that diamond
I'm always upset that we're not covering
the kind of stories that people ought to
be hearing about and and I agree we
don't do as good a job as we ought to be
doing and and the San Diego Union is a
very good paper it's a conservative one
I think I think they do a good job
though they have good editors and
there's no well there's nobody sitting
in the out of this shell we got a slant
the nose to stick it to the Liberals
they stick it to the right wing there's
no one sits in the newsrooms thinking
like that but yet that view somehow
persist out there that the journalists
are not to get somebody that's not it
I've never found that to be true I'm
saying that that our errors come from
from not being a diligent about about
researching our facts and and second not
going after the stories that we ought to
and giving you the full facts it took it
took about 12 years for the dark on
shield story to really break remember
those high you DS that were hurting a
lot of women begin 1974 so now we're
just finding out the full facts where
were the median back then
Warwick Rhode Island good morning do you
have your newspaper okay what's on the
front page mean you get money back from
your your taxes state taxes which would
you like to have sending out $30
[Music]
I would very much like to hear his
comment on whether he thinks through how
much spaces in fact there is all right
thanks for the call any comment oh I
think I think this
I think Reagan's obsession with
Nicaragua in the Sindh and these days is
an absolutely I think history will judge
that is one of the great shames of this
administration we should have been
helping that government sending them
foreign aid sending them Hospital aid
sending them food sending the Peace
Corps kids instead we mined their
harbors we set the poor to fighting
other poor people of Nicaragua
supplying the CIA supplying weapons to
the Contras and those are just poor boys
shooting other poor boys the poor are
always set to killing the poor and
Reagan administration is behind that
there's great a great shame in that we
should have been helping this country
instead instead of course we don't we
cut off the sugar exports imports things
like that make it as hard as we can for
them and then wonder why they go seeking
help from other countries and now that
they maybe are getting a couple of
nickels from somebody oh oh look at that
they're taking money from somebody else
which way do we want to can't they if
they just deal straightly once in a
while with somebody this is a poor
country overthrew one of the most
corrupt violent regimes in Central
American history and
and spill their own blood doing it and
then and then we go in and say well
while you're not quite the way we like
you to be so we're gonna make it hard
for you you're a little too friendly to
some of the commies after all they're
not commies sympathizers there that
people who sympathize with getting food
for the kids getting schools getting rid
of illiteracy getting rid of hunger
unemployment and we'd go in a big rough
USA and kick them around so we go in in
it but we haven't been able to beat them
so we go over to pick on grenada Reagan
is a big tough guy he can beat up
Grenada
that's a forest it's a shame Kenny wick
washed and goodmorning do you have your
newspaper and the front page what's on
the front page well this is kind of a
stepchild of Apache chain why City
Herald
we got only one national story on the
front page and it's down the lower left
hand corner but this your wrong time you
have a picture of the Space Shuttle
taking off on the front page Artie you
have a picture of the Space Shuttle
taking oh yeah there's a picture of the
Space Shuttle taking off but there's no
story on it just says underneath its
secret shuttle though the stories back
on page 11 what do you think of the
secrecy surrounding that mission all I
think the generals are playing I don't
know they act like a bunch of kids
playing the cowboy you know that's
that's why opinions of that bother you
that the Pentagon was saying it was
national security and it shouldn't be
printed but there were journalists
writing stories about it oh my gosh
there were stories out about it prior to
them even saying that now whether
whether they they're not managing your
own store very well because these things
to get out and then they get incensed
because they get printed well somebody
let them out you know and and how do we
know we do know that there is control
leaks going on all the time now how do
we know that's a control leak or whether
it was an actual leak here or somebody
spilled it okay there's no way of
knowing question or comment think these
things should be
when they get out my god if you say any
part of my house the Russian authorities
know all hell a lot more about we do
that mean that we then we do on public
question or comment for Coleman McCarthy
part did you have a question
specifically for mr. McCarthy I like to
make a couple comments then I like to
put him in formal question
I read the well the newspapers I've
showed you what kind of newspaper we got
here well in order to get keep informed
at all I read that the Washington well
the weekly edition the Washington Post
and I also recoil to do Republic in
common cause which will show you my
Mylene probably I'm a Democrat I don't
know what I'm a liberal Democrat or not
but I am again okay but there I have a
concern and you have disgusted somewhat
on the program this morning
my concern is brought on by the handling
of the press of the black salt suit
against the Sacramento Bee the liable
suit for 250 million it was filed last
September and also the richard allen
thing that keeps reoccurring you're
popping up in the zoo it doesn't pop up
that often but both of these people have
had their attorneys right through the
various news media the three networks
and some of the leading newspapers like
the times and the post these sort of
things threatening them with lawsuits if
or with libel suits if they continue
digging into their affairs or continue
pretty and it concerns me that
particularly after the last sort of the
lacs hawk letters
[Applause]
CBS admitted well Mike Wallace did 60
minutes had done a segment but he said
we've had a shock placed across our bow
and they didn't do the segment that
we're supposed to come out on the 23rd
of September and there had been
practically nothing
in the press or on the network about the
lacs offshoot from Sacramento beef and
you're so you're saying that because of
the Westmoreland case CBS is not showing
that story about the lack salt case
Shiraz
there's been an abundance of these cases
pop up ok these these public figures
having their attorneys write letters
threatening new media with suits and the
news media responding by by downplaying
that it aroused the fear in my mind is
the news media being intimidated kenny
wick washington thanks for the call is
the news media being intimidated I can't
answer for everybody I know I've never
been I've been stopped by anybody's
telling me you do right that you're
gonna get in trouble I've never been
scared off I know of no I know Ben
Bradley's never been scared off by
anybody maybe some other fellows are
everybody's gonna answer for themselves
whether they're gonna be pushed around
by some some of those and what you write
write about their case are there there
there are possible actions that the
other want to nice yeah
sure people are gonna try to push you
around scary but I've never been scared
off I don't know anybody I mean my
colleagues at my paper who have been
maybe some others have but probably some
of the smaller operations around the
country that can't afford to hire
defense attorneys they you know they got
to think about the bucks a little bit
more than the big other big and the big
guys you get lots of letters from people
who disagree with what you say Oh most
of my mails from people like that lady
in San Diego I mean she was very mild
she was very nice to me compared to what
I get from San Diego and I don't mind
that at targets ducking mail that high
every morning from folks and I'm an
absolute menace and I as one guy sends
me a stamp he says go to Russia and he
yeah yeah he cuts out my calm go to
Russia and
if it if he'd only send me some F yeah
for every kind of letter he got on
postage I could have gone to Russia
several times and back Wichita Kansas
good morning do you have your newspaper
liquor got a story here on IRS changer
car rule so when that the farmer takes
is picked up out into the barnyard he
don't have to to make a log of it I'd
like to make a comment on some of the
things that your guest has been sharing
and immediately since I am 59 I lived
through this period of time of great
turmoil in the world and I can say to
him nobody hates war any more than I I
was in at the age of 17 in World War two
I remained in the service through Korea
and portions of the Beaton are more but
this peace approach that you that you
give us it's not sellable it will not
sell what I'm going to tell you why you
tell us that we shouldn't continue to
develop technology to defend our country
but let's go back to history you said
you was a teacher earlier so certainly
you must not just teach in the about the
things in the future
you must talk about them now in order to
educate your class you must talk about
the past let's talk about the past for a
moment we would be a defeated country
today if we hadn't found out about the
Germans on the verge of inventing the
atomic bomb President Roosevelt had the
foresight to expand peace the Manhattan
Project he went ahead with that and of
course we was the first nation sadly
enough to use it but nevertheless we
saved more lives than we took by using
it now if you think for one moment and I
don't believe it that you really believe
everything it's you you put out with
that too if you think for one moment by
making everybody in this country very
comfy everything their heart's desire
Uncle Sam provide jobs
dirty food education trips out and the
fish time caller now let me make it
short after I can I'll get off but if
you think for one moment remember we had
the only nation in the world that had
the atomic bomb we could have controlled
Russia we could have control the world
but what did we do we couldn't prepare
no way but the Russian came up with the
atomic bomb I'm running at a time so
we're gonna have to give mr. McCarthy a
chance to respond because we're just
about out thanks for the call mr.
McCarthy Thank You Carl the history is
that violence has failed we have 41 wars
in the world right now the nukes have
not served us dropping the bomb on the
Japanese did not end war the wars are
still going on the boys are still
fighting the poor boys 35 million have
been killed since 1945 and Wars there
has to be another way
and the way as Christ and Gandhi and
King and hundreds of others have been
educating us or trying to is that
violence fails and non-violence is the
only other option that doesn't guarantee
success but it is surefire a more
succeeding than violence and I've
enjoyed being on your show car you're a
terrific guy and you have a great
audience I must have I admire everybody
and particularly those who disagree with
me I love folks who disagree with me I
love to mix it up with everybody and I'm
glad to be on the program : with Karthi
has been our guest this is the picture
of him on the front cover of his book is
that the same bike you rode down to our
studios on yes it certainly is now I'm
glad nobody ran none of those big car
owners ran me over they call I'm sure
you were one of them but thank you for
not killing me today
Karthi thank you for being our guest
those of you have been watching those of
you called we appreciate it have a nice
Friday
[Music]
[Music]